good evening and welcome to a special
edition of
tucker carlson tonight tucker's out for
what passes for the holiday these stays
i'm mark stein happy thanksgiving
chicago mayor laurie lightfoot
you must cancel the normal thanksgiving
plans
particularly if they include guests that
do not live in your immediate household
isn't guests that do not live in your
immediate household the whole idea of
thanksgiving over the river and through
the wood to grandfather's house we go
because that's the best way to avoid the
state police checkpoint on highway 37.
as is traditional president trump has
pardoned a turkey at the white house
any chance of the governors of maine or
michigan or new jersey
pardoning their recalcitrant
hairdressers or gym owners or
restaurateurs
not a chance those guys have to be
stuffed and carved up
as an example to any others among our
rulers subjects
minded to get a little restless 400
years after the puritans set sail
because they wish to hold open
public religious services open public
religious services have been deemed
non-essential in the old country you had
to hold them in private houses but don't
even think of doing that here if you
shake off the coppers
and make it back to the old homestead
what
is the maximum number of persons that a
freeborn american
is allowed to have in his home this
thanksgiving in arkansas colorado
connecticut delaware on and on
it's 10. in kentucky it's eight
people from no more than two households
in california you can have people from
up to three households
but you have to disperse after two hours
even if you're outdoors you're on the
clock
it's like a parking meter but you can't
keep coming back and pumping it with
extra quarters governor newsome and the
grand viziers of
public health dining at the french
laundry in napa valley can linger over
the aperitifs
and a moose bush all the way to the
cognacs and mint wafers
but you've got to chow down that butter
ball and scram
in oregon the maximum number permitted
in a private home is
six persons in new mexico five in
vermont and rhode island you can
socialize
only with those you already live with so
take a look around the room that's it
that's your thanksgiving
the same kids have been off school for a
year the same spouse you've been cooped
up with
since the two of you got deemed
non-essential back in march cabin fever
is coming early to vermont
the centers for disease control which
has proved incapable of controlling the
disease
and so would rather control you instead
because frankly it's a lot easier
advises that you should take your own
thanksgiving meal with you take your own
turkey take your own stuffing take your
own fix things
especially take your own cranberry sauce
because that's a
super spreader and take your own
disposable plate and utensils and be
sure to throw them away immediately
you're finished
lest auntie mabel carelessly pick up
your plastic spoon
to stir her pumpkin spice metamucil
but don't get the idea that thanksgiving
isn't going to be any fun
if you live in a state that still
permits you to dine with persons
from another household why not tickle
their ribs
from a socially responsible distance on
the other side of the room with a
thanksgiving themed
mask here's emmy award-winning senior
care facility manager
andrew cuomo we have a special mask
for thanksgiving because you know we're
also creative in new york
we are creative and we do things a
little different
and we have a special mask don't
be a turkey this thanksgiving wear
a mask don't be a turkey
how good looking is this mask right you
ready
look at that and they said
vaudeville was dead in andrew cuomo's
hands vaudeville isn't but everything
else is
you have to give it to chairman xi and
those chaicoms how many
foreign adversaries could come up with a
new virus
that results in a pandemic of andrew
cuomo sight gags
all over the state there will be empty
seats at the thanksgiving table for
elderly new yorkers
whose last moments of life were filled
with their lethal governor's
visual comedy for christmas uh could
governor cuomo
maybe order up a turkey hazmat suit and
flap about
in the icu oregon's kate brown knows
that to govern
is to prioritize in portland the
anarchists have had the run of the city
all year and fortunately that frees up a
lot of law enforcement
to investigate whether grandma is
dishing up the sprouts and butternut
squash
for an illegal seventh diner i will be
asking
our oregon state police to work
collaboratively with local law
enforcement
to enforce the limits on social
gatherings they are
classy misdemeanors and they can be
enforced through a citation a fine
or through an arrest at this point in
time unfortunately we have
no other option
america 2020 thanksgiving is a class c
misdemeanor why not take it to the next
level governor cuomo says
with a straight face the new york police
chiefs who refuse to enforce
thanksgiving lockdowns are quote
dictators
so if you're bored with turning in your
neighbors for having a sixth seventh
eighth ninth guest why not turn
in your local police department for
refusing to send round the thanksgiving
swat team
in vermont schools next week the little
boys and girls and the non-binary
muppets will be asked if they
and their parents attended thanksgiving
gatherings
involving persons from other households
did grandma come round come on kid you
gotta answer because nothing says
thanksgiving like snitching on your mar
and power
need a drink forget it for the last
three hours
pennsylvania has been a dry state liquor
stores have closed
four thanksgiving fortunately for
pennsylvanians
it's easy to convert the xerox machine
you used to print the mail-in ballots
into a still for bootleg hooch the
governor says the booze ban is necessary
it turns out that the biggest day for
drinking is the wednesday before
thanksgiving
and and when people get together in that
situation it leads to an increase
in the exchange of
the the fluids that leads to increased
infection
i'm really not sure he needed to ban the
booze
a because dr fauci's already signed off
on casual sex hookups and b
because for most pennsylvanians the most
effective disinfect
disincentive to the exchange of the
fluids
is hearing governor wolf talking about
the exchange of the fluids
after that sound bite i don't plan on
exchanging any fluids this side of
groundhog day
in new mexico governor grisham has
ordered grocery stores closed
drink is non-essential and now food is
non-essential which makes a lot of sense
if you are non-essential clearly
the sustenance required to keep you
alive is
likewise non-essential